leute hier ist wieder einmal war ja ich
jetzt auf meiner couch glaube mir
gefällt es so ich glaube es kann so
bleiben ich müsste nur irgendwie hier
hinten mal was aufhängen damit das
irgendwie cool aussieht aber ich habe
eine schöne lampe die sieht man zwar
nicht ganz dabei legen wir los
ja ich stelle mir die eine große frage
denn ich tue ich weiß nein er muss ganz
viel segen
ich tue es du tust es selbst meine
schwester tut ist ich glaube meine
mutter tut es auch wir abonnieren
youtube-kanäle meistens die große frage
ist nun warum tun wir das was verleitet
uns dazu einen kanal zu abonnieren
und was muss ein kanal haben damit wir
ihn abonnieren
ich glaube das kann eigentlich keiner so
richtig beantworten denn sonst hätten
wir schon mehr kanäle mit über eine
million abonnenten wenn jemand weiß was
man tun muss damit man viele abonnenten
hat immer infos zu mir
obwohl ich tief im inneren weiß was ich
dafür tun müsste
ihr merkt auf jeden fall ich beschäftige
mich mit dem thema ich denke mal das tut
jeder youtuber wenn er youtube videos
macht weil es youtuber ist das ist das
was youtuber machen oder youtube videos
manchmal machen sie auch youtube videos
auf dvds aber dass es dann wieder ein
ganz anderes thema ich wollte noch
nichts mittel gehabt bin nicht mit
meinem kopf da und jetzt schreiben
wieder irgendwelche leute meine videos
sinnvoll und strukturiert ich komm nicht
hinterher
ja wenn ich deine lehrerin die irgendein
vortrag hält
ich kenne auch am anfang der gliederung
an die seite schreiben einleitung
hauptteil schluss und dann muss ich mich
immer daran halten was da energie darum
steht
ich gebe euch jetzt gründe warum ich zum
beispiel ein kanal abonnieren
grund 1 wohltätigkeit damit meine ich
eigentlich dass ich im kanal ganz nett
finde und eigentlich auch die videos
ganz gut so weit aber irgendwas
verleitet mich dazu diesen kanal pushen
zu wollen und ihnen einen weiteren
abonnenten schenken zu wollen weil ich
finde dass die person ist dann verdient
hat nicht weil ich jetzt unbedingt die
videos fire oder weil das mein geschmack
trifft aber ich habe das gefühl dass ich
immer dass ich den abonnieren muss so
mit der eins mehr ist es wie ein euro
spenden für mich spenden-euro ich bin
der abonnenten sei da gucke ich mir dann
die videos auch nie so wirklich an aber
diese 301 abonnenten mehr und das ist
doch um es geht
nein eigentlich jetzt um die aufrufe
trotzdem sieht schön aus und dann denken
die ganzen firmen so der hat aber viele
abonnenten der ist wichtig und dann
macht er nur schrott davon jetzt ein
paar
grund zwei netze
nein ich meine ich diese mütze ich mein
belohnen milchtüten putenbrust es ist
jetzt nicht so ein grund warum ich ein
kanal abonniere aber ich glaube es ist
wirklich auch ausschlaggebend für viele
andere
jetzt könnte man sagen dass das falsch
ist aber ich habe mich auch schon auf
dabei erwischt dass ich nur auf dem
video geklickt hat weil da war
ordentlich was zu sehen war und
natürlich die neugier in sagt kommen
video darauf möglichst meistens ist
nicht so ich kenne ein paar die oft
bussen in die links rein tun und dann
keine busen zu sehen sind
und irgendwer klopft hier ignoriert oder
es gibt diese eine die gitarre spielt
mit ihren ordentlichen wo sie so und es
lief erst gut als sie dann hier immer
die bösen drauf getan hat läuft grund
nummer drei
viele abonnenten ich mein wenn ich auf
dem kanal so bin und dann denke ich mir
ja coole videos und einen sehe ich wie
viele abonnenten die haben verleitet
mich das oft schneller dazu auch zu
abonnieren weil ich mir denkt okay die
masse magst ein ganzes verhalten das
darf man eigentlich nicht tun wenn man
ein individueller mensch sein möchte
darf man das nicht tun aber ich man tut
so öfter mal und dann abonniere ich weil
viele den abonnieren ich meine gute idee
finde ich jetzt wirklich lustig den
nicht gut an der seite könig aber
natürlich denken sich andere leute auch
33 millionen alles klar
der muss das haben was ich aussehen wird
dann abonnieren sie alle weiter grund
nummer vier besessenheit
es gibt kanäle auf die ich komme und
irgendwas hat diese person dass mich das
so fasziniert die muss auch gar nicht so
wirklich was atemberaubendes neues coole
ist alles machen aber diese person hieß
dann einfach so zweistellig letztens den
michael buch in dem buch ina michael
buchinger hier
den habe ich entdeckt und damals auch so
also der macht gute
jetzt muss ich sagen er macht wirklich
lustige videos aber er macht halt auch
nichts was so atem raubt neuesten nicht
schon auf anderen kanälen auch geben
könnte aber das ist so ein mensch den
fenstern so sympathisch ist so eine
besessenheit entwickelt und einfach die
videos schauen muss diese person feiern
eigentlich könnte sie dir was vom
fernsehen und erlauben oder als sich
herr zeit vor die kamera setzen und
lassen sie wäre egal
die hintergrundgeräusche werden wir
gerade echt zu viel da hinten klopft die
futures machen gerade da ist irgend eine
baustelle und ich sitze hier und will
einfach nur mal vier minuten meine ruhe
was aufnehmen also ich aufgeschrieben
jetzt läuft wieder durch ihr zu
also mich würde interessieren wie viele
abonnenten ihr ungefähr habe weil ich
bin mit meinem 45 echt gut bedient
könnte aber auch mal mehr haben also mir
gefallen auch viel mehr kanäle
ich bin immer so eine angst dass das
übersicht verlieren was eigentlich auch
doof ist weil youtube erinnert daran was
die anderen so machen
und ja aber auch nicht so schlimm hatte
ich das noch nie und dieses klopfen hört
nicht auf
dann sag ich tschüss für heute leute
hier gibt's noch sowie die joh